Germany's Oktoberfest is well underway...
...with millions enjoying the annual beer festival,...
...but it's not only Munich that is hosting a special beer festival.
In the tiny Palestinian village of Taybeh,...
...thousands of locals and visitors have enjoyed their own German inspired Oktoberfest,...
...and descended on the village which claims to produce the only Palestinian beer.
And my friend Simon told me about this festival here,...
...and he said it's like the Oktoberfest in Germany,...
...and I thought if something here is like in Germany,...
...I will go here.
The Taybeh Festival, which began in 2005,...
...is a world away from the Gaza Strip,...
...the other area Palestinians want for their future state,...
...where the Islamic militant group Hamas has forbidden alcohol...
...and imposed severe rules for men and women in public.
Today, many Palestinians see the Taybeh Festival...
...as an opportunity to boost the sagging local economy,...
...and many go to enjoy Palestinian music and dance troupes,...
...and quite a few more simply want to quaff the local ale.